à chardonnay les réunions discrètes se
multiplient la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse et l'association sauvegarde
71 ont en effet le projet d'installer
ici un centre éducatif fermé
la population et les élus l'ont appris
par hasard il dénonce un dossier monté
dans l'opacité
le manque de transparence il commence
par le fait qu' on a été informés à une
date où les choses étaient déjà
tellement engagé qu'on peut pratiquement
plus reculés à savoir la signature du
premier vingt selon nos informations
l'association sauvegarde 71 proposerait
570 mille euros et envisagerait de faire
huit mois de travaux la note finale
pourrait avoisiner le million d'euros
car ce n'est pas une simple bâtisse qui
est transformé en centre éducatif fermé
les uns château et datent du 19e c'est
une propriété donc acquise par un
général de napoléon iii inquiet pour
lequel il va donner pour faits d'armes
et puis donc c'est effectivement une
bâtisse donc il fait partie du
patrimoine du village les entoure et il
est entouré de devine la propriété
possède également un grand parc arboré
et une piscine
tout cela situe en plein centre de ce
village de 230 habitants 99% d'entre eux
ont signé une pétition contre ce centre
éducatif fermé
nous avons peur bien sûr bon comme vous
pouvez constater ce château est au
milieu des maisons
il ya beaucoup de rivera au tourne
autour de ce château les élus de tous
bords sont également posées au projet
ils craignent notamment pour l'image du
cépage chardonnay
il préférerait que le château accueille
un projet oenotouristique
on a un nom prédestiné chardonnay est
connu dans le monde entier
je crois que pour l'économie c'est pas
avec un chef qu'on va développer notre
notre territoire
ni les services du ministère de la
justice
6 ni l'association sauvegarde 71 n'ont
accepté de répondre à nos questions